what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with X-Men red I.E the Omega
Level mutant Civil War yes this is part
of Marvel's fall of X event but it is
also a little bit separate at the same
time for those of you guys who are
behind you'll find a link to the fall of
X playlist at the end of this video but
the long and short of what's going on
here is that this takes place after the
stalemate which is to say the forces of
storm versus the forces of Genesis what
does that mean so a lot of you guys
already know who storm is Genesis is
kind of the antithesis to storm in a lot
of different ways they're very similar
but they're very different storm fights
for justice and the rights of mutant
kind and so on and so forth all the
things you normally expect from the
mutant population but Genesis and her
forces come from arako this long lost
land out there in another dimension that
was filled with mutants that we never
knew about before who were all just
overpowered but the war between Genesis
and storm is really awesome because
Genesis Only Knows War she believes that
like you'll be tested on the battlefield
field and if you survive you'll be
stronger for the Victory and mutants
just need to consistently be as strong
as possible the problem here is that in
the fight they had neither side could
overcome the other so a kind of
ceasefire at least an unofficial
ceasefire was called in the sense that
Genesis retreated her forces and now
she's taking to the Sea and this is due
to the fact that she realizes that among
Storm's forces they don't have anyone
that can control the water they don't
have anybody that can control the oceans
name where the Submariner is not here
and one of the things that we would
largely have to assume I don't know if
Marvel's really confirmed this the way
they have with storm and being able to
manipulate the weather unlike any planet
or even in space I don't know if Namo
the Submariner would be able to dominate
sea life on another world but even then
it doesn't matter because what happens
here is that when Genesis gets her
forces to the ocean her stance is we are
going to manipulate sea life for our own
ends so we can literally take take the
various organisms in the ocean and
bolster our forces and use them against
storm now sobinar is totally against
this and sobinar is kind of like genesis
version of name of the Submariner right
that kind of character Namor is a
mutants within Marvel Comics he's
usually part of the Avengers or the
X-Men Associates with them Loosely so on
and so forth but sobinar commands the
Seas and the response to sobinar is I'm
not okay with you doing this but the
response of Genesis is it doesn't matter
so what she ends up doing is basically
approaching like Cohen who is basically
a werewolf with two heads and the idea
here is that it represents stalemates
now that's one of the things for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with the
forces of arako everything is symbolism
the roles that people play their
physical appearance oftentimes directly
reflects the role they play with like
Cohen it's one of these things where
both heads are able to kind of see the
most logical course that they can take
and while it's not really precognitive
in the sense that he can't see the
future it's more or less seducing logic
and reason and his response is we should
defer to you great Genesis on all things
now the reality here is that Genesis is
vying for power and she could easily
kill almost everybody here I say almost
because there's one person here whom she
could never harm but in reality as part
of a play for power people will
effectively bend the knee in order to
earn the favor of the person that's
vying for power so you can make a
legitimate argument here that like
Cohen's basically lying right and
essentially saying well of course we
need to follow your wisdom great Genesis
of course we should do that because it
Curry's favor with Genesis so that when
the time comes when this war is
basically over and as far as they're
concerned she becomes the absolute ruler
then that in turn would basically allow
them to Curry favor with her and achieve
some high-ranking position or something
along those lines but there are others
who stand against her but then Aura
Serrata steps in and says let there be
silence this is what's going to happen
so the question has to be asked how is
it that aura Serrata can just dominate
the entirety of the conversation because
or Serrata is crazy overpowered over
Serrata is so ridiculously op but there
is a caveat right so Aura Serrata sits
on this giant eye and the thing about
this is that the eye will wipe from
existence whatever it looks at if or
Serrata fires a beam of energy at you
you will cease to exist right like
that's it done gone forever but the
kicker about this is you have to be a
believer which is to say you have to be
someone who submits themselves to the
laws of orasarata and these mutants that
exist on Mars if you don't like she
can't really do anything to you in the
case of Genesis she's a Believer so if
ursarada turns her gaze to Genesis it's
game over right that's it Genesis is
done and gone and so when or Serrata
steps up and says no these are how
things are going to be she basically
says sadist Exotica you have legal
permission to proceed and what saddest
Exotica can do is basically transmogrify
sea life in effect mutate and modify
existing life that's out there and so by
cutting his hand and dripping his blood
into the water one of these fish if you
want to call it that again it's a lot of
symbolism right one of them is chosen to
imbue the great power of these arako
mutants and then like jump into The Fray
and help them in their fight against
storm and her forces and so at that
point you switch over to storm and what
ends up happening in the Citadel where
her forces are taking up residence in
this moment of reprieve is one of these
mutated fish emerges as just like this
gigantic sea monster now any reasonable
person would look at this and say oh my
God right they would be overwhelmed they
would be fearful so on and so forth not
storm let me tell you something man
storm sun sun sun sun dude storm this is
one of the reasons why I love storm so
much this chick is fearless man this
girl knows no fear like literally she
sees this thing and she's like nope not
happening that is not going to happen
today because for someone like storm
whether or not a foe can be overcome has
nothing to do with their physical size
absolutely nothing to do with it storm
is one of these where she maintains
almost just complete and total
confidence in her abilities almost 100
of the time because to mess with storm
is to mess with the power of the world
itself the entire Earth ecosystem right
the weather it's it's a Fool's errand
it's really what it is so what this
chick does is she flies up into the air
it's one of the most boss things that I
think I've ever seen storm do she flies
up into the air she manipulates the cold
literally she freezes the air and the
ambient water vapor and creates like
this gigantic Spike of ice and brings
the thing crashing down into this
Monster's head and just like that the
whole thing's done dunzer dead and like
just just like that this is why storm is
so overpowered and so amazing in Marvel
Comics because in years past in Marvel
it was just kind of like I can make it
really cold or I can make it really warm
or I can fly using the wind or I can
like blow you 10 feet in that direction
but over the years in Marvel Comics man
Storm's Powers have just been like
manipulated and adjusted and changed
with unique ways to use them by
different writers over the course of
Marvel Comics and you just end up with
like moments like this where it's
absolutely insane and so in response to
that what you end up having is kind of
like a spy quote unquote that starts to
manifest that this is basically a
gigantic trojan horse that's all this
was it was never about sending this
monster in to destroy the forces of
storm it was sending this monster in to
unleash a greater monster and initially
it's fisher king right kind of one of
the generals of storm that initially
figures this out that when this monster
lays dead its back cracks open and then
these Vines start to emerge and as soon
as that happens fisher king immediately
figures out right he tells Robert
DeCosta who can like burn at like the
heat of the sun he tells this guy like
destroy the vines right right now burn
the corpse but the fact is it's too late
these Vines start to emerge and then a
giant portal right literally an okara
gate starts to open up what's an okara
gate do okara gates are the Gateway
between the dimensional realm of arako
out there in whatever landscape it
happens to be in and the real world for
this gate to basically build and to
activate God only knows what's coming
from the other side but fisher king
effectively knows he can make an
incredibly accurate guess because
remember on the other side of this is a
whole host of just demonic beings unless
we forget that golden helmet that
Genesis is wearing that's the helmet of
ameth anybody who wears that helmet
controls these demonic forces and so
once that happens and that gate opens up
Genesis literally says invade move
forward and through this gate are not
just these demonic forces but the
children of Apocalypse right these four
the guy who looks like a pharaoh the guy
who looks like Anubis the one with their
head on fire the one with like the red
Dome and the two spikes sticking up
right the white king and his 100 forces
like the 100 soldiers who cannot die who
are basically Immortal they all come
pouring through if ever there were an
instance where Storm and her forces had
no chance to survive this is it because
this war is effectively done so unless
something comes out of somewhere that
can bolster the powers of storm or the
forces of storm there's no conceivable
way that they can win with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
you guys click this link to the playlist
peace